invité de notre journal dominique sanda
pour les survivants de la fin du monde
didier six un but qui aurait pu changer
bien des choses
elle a 30 ans elle est handicapée à 100
% on va saisir ses meubles pour
non-paiement de contraventions la
campagne de boycott contre shell la cour
de paris
un jugement de salomon
la mémoire et messieurs bonjour au delà
de tous ces types de tous ces gros
dossiers d'actualité il y à un cas
humain qui nous a tous émus c'est un
petit drame qui ne change pas la face du
monde mais qui pourtant est bien
révélateur de certains blocages de
certaine détresse après demain jeudi
un huissier guen aurait effectué une
saisie mobilière ou au domicile d'une
jeune femme de 30 ans cela arrive tous
les jours elle n'avait pas payer ses
contraventions depuis longtemps
seulement elizabeth
or leur batteur est handicapé moteur à
100% et elle a réussi ce que l'on
appelle son insertion dans une société
de gens qui marchent avec leurs jambes
mais à un moment est arrivé ce blocage
administratif bête sans raku babet c'est
comme cela que tout le monde l'appelle à
l' agence de publicité où elle travaille
licencié en droit de s de sciences
politiques et de droit public
ce n'est pas rien lorsqu'on est
handicapé moteur à 100% et que dès son
plus jeune âge il faut lutter pour être
accepté comme les autres dans un
établissement d'enseignement public par
la suite à diplôme égal
il faut continuer à se battre pour
travailler en dehors des ateliers
protégés
pourtant bab et thierry ce serait une
insertion professionnelle exemplaire
s'il n'y avait pas ce détail trop bête
l' agence qui l'emploie ne possède pas
de garage souterrain situé rue du pont
neuf à paris il est presque impossible
de se garer et babeth est obligé de
venir travailler en voiture sur son pare
brise
le macaron de grand invalide civil ne
lui sert à rien makarov permet une
tolérance une tolérance c'est à dire une
contravention de temps en temps avec des
explications expliquant pour priver la
contravention et huntelaar revenu à deux
par mois en mois j'en ai absolument tous
les jours de la transparence de danse à
seulement
non pas de temps stationnement ça c'est
si vous voulez les contractuels quand on
leur explique qu'il ya un macaron gic
elle vous répondra note d'ailleurs sur
leurs contraventions qui agit qu'avec un
numéro mais l'or nos explications vas-y
c'est à dire que alise stationnement est
limité à 1h à 2h à 3h ne marque que ça
sur leurs contraventions et n'a aucune
qui est d'accord avec et il y en a même
une ya quatre jours qui m'a dit mais non
vous avez le droit de stationner sur les
parts mettre un certain temps quand je
lui ai demandé ce que c'était qu'un
certain m'a dit 'ça certain temps donc
ses explications en fait elles ne savent
pas ce que c'est on ne connaît pas la
tolérance
exact et en fait ça devrait être cas
particuliers par cas particulier on sait
pas le principe de l'administration on
est dans une société qui ne permet pas
l'établissement d'un handicap et pour la
meilleure proche des transports en
commun transport en commun sont faits
pour la généralité mais absolument pas
tous des cas particuliers par exemple
j'ai vite le 20e arrondissement
jeanne autobus qui peut me descendre pas
trop loin ça pratiquement au coin de la
rue et pour aller le rechercher soucy
leur chercher plus loin ses sonorités
associant [ __ ] et bon ça me fait
beaucoup trop loin
alors là la saisie doit avoir lieu jeudi
oui allez bouffer et bon qui viennent
directement avec les commissaires qu'ils
ouvrent et toute façon ma position est
soit je travaille et j'essaye de vivre
avec ce travail je vois pas pourquoi
tout mon travail passeraient d'un
contrat d'un montant des contraventions
dont je vois beaucoup à super livrets
est absolument aucune raison que je paye
ex'im au cros courant graff est refusé
bon ils ont qu'à aller jusqu'au bout
c'est à dire puisqu'ils veulent que je
travaille pendant l'atelier protégé
qu'elle mette en prison envoyé en
atelier protégé je vois pas où est la
raison c'est la réinsertion sociale
babet 4500 francs bruts par mois
elle évalue le montant de ces
contraventions à environ 2000 francs par
mois
en quatre années elle doit donc à
l'administration près de 10 millions de
centimes
oui une bavure diront certains le la
saisine vaut la peine jeudi la politique
maintenant une actualité en attente en
attente de la conférence de presse que
doit tenir demain 16 heures le jour de
la sainte elysées le président de la
république on sait d'ores et déjà que le
chef de l'état commencera par un petit
exposé dans lequel il donnera des pistes
pour les trois gros dossiers qui seront
abordés
d'abord les problèmes intérieurs et un
site
elle ensuite l'économique et le social
ont dit qu'il compte annoncer des
initiatives pour la justice et le
progrès social afin de lutter contre le
chômage et la hausse des prix enfin la
situation internationale et la politique
étrangère de la france avec bien
évidemment un gros noyau africain
antenne 2 a décidé d'innover cette année
en vous présentant deux édition spéciale
du journal la première à 18 heures
animée par patrick lecocq avec les
meilleurs moments de cette conférence de
presse et puis après une heure trois
quarts de football allemagne italie en
direct j'aurai le plaisir de vous
retrouver mai à 20h30 pour un journal de
trois quarts d'heure cette fois avec
bien entendu
extraits et commentaires ce soir c'est
le premier ministre qui est monté en
première ligne à l'occasion d'un débat
organisé par notre confrère les échos
dans un grand hôtel parisien raymond
barre qui a réaffirmé avec beaucoup de
fermeté sa volonté de garder même pas et
bien dans la mesure où je suis parce que
je suis premier ministre
cette politique continue et croyez bien
que je n'ai pas l'intention de change il
faut que cela soit clair
comme je ne me livre pas à l'activité de
premier ministre par plaisir ni par
satisfaction d'un intense désir
je n'ai pas l'intention de modifier une
ligne que je crois indispensable à la
survie de ce pays
les responsabilités que je porte sont
des responsabilités à l'égard du pays
elles ne sont pas des responsabilités à
l'égard de tel groupe social ou de
telles formations politiques
et quand on situe la france dans le
monde tel qu'il est il n'est pas
possible de pratiquer le compromis
habile
ni la complaisance facile bien chaud il
faut de temps à autres admettre les culs
accepter quelques scories et laisser
passer quelques fantaisies
mais pour l'essentiel il faut que le cap
choix fixé et il faut que le cas soit
une septième jour de grève ou d'assyrie
de pompey qui emploie 4000 200 employés
l'arrêt de travail décidée par les 160
ouvriers des eaux des hauts fourneaux
parlant paralyse progressivement toute
l'entreprise
en lorraine la cftc et force ouvrière se
joignent à l'appel lancé par la cgt
d'une grève de 24 heures le 16 juin dans
les mines de fer grève aussi à l'arsenal
de brest où les ouvriers occupent depuis
ce matin leur atelier lui 1000 salariés
travaillent à l'arsenal mais les trois
principaux points chauds reste encore
aujourd'hui renault manufrance et les
tanneries française rêver les consignes
débrayage de deux heures lancée par les
syndicats on était peu suivi aujourd'hui
aux usines renault le nombre de
grévistes n'a guère dépassé dès pour
sans exception du mans où il atteignait
près du quart des ouvriers à flins
malgré la désignation d'un médiateur
l'atelier dé grande place est toujours
occupée 80 ouvriers de cet atelier
convoqué par la direction sont menacés
de licenciement
malgré ce conflit la direction annoncé
cet après midi une augmentation de
salaire de 1,5 pour cent et le versement
des trois primes d'un total de 4,6
hier soir en sortant de chez rené monory
françois gado le pdg de manufrance était
satisfait mais pas sans inquiétude
certes le gouvernement a fait un geste
un prêt de 5 à 8 millions mais manu
france en espérait 40
pourtant ce prêt c'est un peu l'aval
officiel qu'attendaient les
investisseurs privés pour s'engager non
ne sait pas encore combien le ferons
reste aussi à faire accepter aux
personnels les 334 licenciements et la
renégociation de certains avantages
acquis
ce ne sera certes pas le plus facile
m'étonnerait françaises réunies mise en
règlement judiciaire depuis le 24 avril
risque d'être fermé définitivement à la
fin de la semaine
syndicat s'oppose toujours au plan de
redressement qui prévoit cinq cent
soixante deux licenciements
ils demandent la réintégration des
licenciés cette société était encore il
ya peu de temps
l'une des premières entreprises
françaises de traitement du cuir
discussions aujourd'hui à l'assemblée du
projet de loi sur la taxation des plus
values boursières hier soir nous vous
présentions les aspects techniques du
dossier
en voici maintenant les implications
politiques et il semble que le débat se
soit ouverte dans une atmosphère
nettement moins passionné qu'il ya deux
ans bielmann peut tout de même pas
parler d'un enthousiasme délirant et
sans dire comme un leader rpr que les
assemblées novak les textes fixent cox
ou la schlague et bien même les
meilleurs défenseurs de ce projet comme
monsieur millions de l'udf demande à
monsieur pape on le ministre d'accepter
un certain nombre d'amendements alors
est ce que le texte va être votée est ce
qu'on connaît la position du groupe rpr
et bien le rpr qui est un manque
d'intérêt a montré qu' on ne peut rien
faire sans ses voiles laisse planer une
certaine incertitude ce soir et tout en
affirmant qu'il ne faut pas voir là des
arrière-pensées politiques
s'il ne s'agit que d'une attitude
technique monsieur claude labbé le
président du groupe rpr indique qu'il y
aurait des irréductibles alors parmi eux
les parisiens
mais aussi un certain nombre de
provinciaux tel le professeur committee
qui estime que le monstre engendré en 76
n'a pas retrouvé un coup au visage
malgré tous les efforts du chirurgien
esthétique monsieur gbagbo
mais le plus gros de la troupe sera
menée par monsieur marc est qui agit de
tel depuis le début le chiffon rouge et
qui se déterminera en fonction de
l'accueil fait à ces amendements lors il
ya des discussions en coulisses
actuellement avec le premier ministre et
monsieur chez nous qui était à matignon
avec monsieur l'abbé m'a dit que les
choses progressent tant du côté de
l'opposition mad membres d'hermine et
dalian est bien de l'opposition
évidemment ne votera pas ce texte
monsieur fabius le trouble aussi
dérisoire insuffisant et hypocrite et
monsieur combrisson communiste immoral
et tous demandent un nouveau barème
d'imposition pour les fortunes mais je
n'ai des nouveaux et l'udf à l'hôtel
matignon aujourd'hui les députés qui ont
trouvé un premier ministre optimiste
quant à l'issue du combat qu'il conduit
c'est ce qu'a déclaré l'un d'entre eux
maurice chartier député du vaucluse
jacques blanc le nouveau secrétaire
général du parti républicain veut
engager son mouvement dans la voie de la
solidarité
il n'ya pas de secteur qui échappe à
cette notion at il dit c'est ce que nous
opposons à la lutte des classes jacques
blanc a par ailleurs profité pour
adresser quelques piques à l'égard du
président du rpr jacques chirac qui
avait tenu des propos assez rude sur la
politique étrangère du président de la
république la semaine dernière vous
pourrez entendre jacques blanc s'en
expliquer dans notre dernier journal la
cour d'appel de paris a confirmé
aujourd'hui le jugement du tribunal
civil qui interdisait la campagne de
boycott des produits de la société shell
elle a toutefois supprimé la provision
de 10 mille francs accordés par le
premier tribunal à la compagnie
pétrolière jugement de salomon diront
certains qui estiment que le principe
d'un boycott n'a pas du tout été
repoussée par à courre le boycott une
arme encore assez mal connue en france
les salariés se mettent en grève les
commerçants baissent le rideau
quant aux consommateurs leur harnes
c'est le boycott c'est à dire la grève
des agents une arme pour l'instant peu
utilisé en france où les appels au
boycott sont rares et rencontre assez
peu d'écho
malgré tout les organisations de
consommateurs sont persuadés qu'un jour
ou l'autre les boycotts seront admis au
même titre que le droit de grève et déjà
les campagnes de boycott se multiplient
contre les aérosols contre les colorants
alimentaires et dernièrement contre
shell mise en cause dans la catastrophe
de l'amoco cadiz
pourtant les consommateurs français
restent encore sceptiques sur
l'efficacité d'un boycott
si on a besoin de quelque chose défend
ses marchés alors moi moi je trouve pas
plus efficace
est ce que vous êtes favorable au
boycott ah oui il fera pas mal de
s'organiser sérieusement pour sa vie
parce qu'on peut remarquer que le prêt
il y en a ils exagèrent
si les consommateurs étaient mieux
organisés sur mon club d'istres et moins
chères elles sont pas sérieux
consommateurs c'est à dire ce n'est pas
tellement efficace que j'ai passé
j'avais vu mais certains produits sont
là c'est qu'ils ont déjà été boycottée
et on continue toujours à les vendre
mais de plus en plus de réclame power
bon je crois pas que ce soit un efficace
un certain fatalisme que ne connaissent
pas les consommateurs américains et
japonais ou le boycott est désormais
entrée dans les habitudes à l'étranger
le boycott des effets extraordinaires
aux usa lorsque les ménagères yorkais se
sont mis spontanément en grève de viande
elles ont fait baisser le prix de la
viande au japon qu'on 15 millions de
consommateurs et japonaise on peut
compter pour lui botter donc une
diminution de 50 % du coût des produits
de beauté alors en france on revenir au
boycott parce que c'est la seule arme
que possède finalement les consommateurs
c'est bien gentil de dire que les
consommateurs ont le droit d'être
informés mais s'ils n'ont pas le droit
d'agir
le boycott est leur seule façon d'agir
contre les 10 milliards de nos francs de
la publicité
aujourd'hui les juges parisiens ont
implicitement reconnu le droit au
boycott pour les consommateurs mais un
droit limité puisque que choisir ne
pourra continuer à boycotter la
compagnie shell une avocate sous les
verrous fut une nouvelle fois le barreau
parisien est en émoi maître de nice
thouanel tournoi 33 ans est inculpé pour
sorties régulières de courrier par une
personne habilitée à avoir des contacts
avec des prisonniers alors dit comme
cela la sphère ne semble guère porté à
conséquence
mais il faut savoir que c'est une série
de perquisitions chez des gangsters et à
son cabinet qui a permis de saisir des
documents compromettants il ya deux
semaines la brigade anti gang avait
interpellé quatre bandits qui
s'apprêtaient à attaquer la poste de
bourg-la-reine près de paris dans leurs
poches des lettres des plans qui leur
seraient parvenues de détenus à la
prison de la santé
alors qui donc a pu faire parvenir ses
plans les soupçons des policiers se sont
porté sur l'avocate la faire je vous le
disais inquiétait les avocats qui
reconnaissent qu'il ya sans doute une
imprudence déontologique c'est ce que
nous a dit au téléphone le bâtonnier
petit é mais qui estime que tout cela
ressemble à une orchestration général de
la police dans un but de suspicion de
satin davoc vi fêtant de prison ferme
pour viol c'est le verdict de la cour
d'assises de perpignan à l'encontre d'un
garçon de café qui avait agressé
plusieurs jeunes filles qu'il avait
prise en stop
c'est la manifestation d'une tendance
assez générale en ce moment des tribunes
et puis je suis une agression cette nuit
à paimpol des militaires du 1er régiment
de hussards parachutistes s'en sont pris
à un élève ivoirien de l'école nationale
de la marine marchande avec des slogans
très raciste l'étudiant est hospitalisé
et la municipalité de paimpol a demandé
le rappel de ce régiment venu en
bretagne pour lutter contre la marée
noire jamais jusqu alors il n'y avait eu
de problème avec ces volontaires venus
aider les bretons à panser leurs plaies
enfin les suites de la faire enfin trois
nouveaux membres de la bande arrêté à
genève et à lisbonne il manque toujours
le cerveau du rapt de l'industriel
françois cayol ainsi que deux autres
comparses la politique étrangère
maintenant avec d'abord ce regain de
tension au liban conseil des ministres
extraordinaire en ce moment le fils de
l'ancien président la république
monsieur frangié a en effet été
assassiné ainsi que sa femme sa fille et
deux serviteurs par des militaires
phalangistes depuis plusieurs jours d
incident armé avec de nombreux morts
opposé les partisans de monsieur frangé
de tendance pourtant conservatrice à ses
militants phalangistes que l'on peut
classer à droite si ce n'est à
l'extrême-droite l'assassinât de tony
frangié a jeté la consternation parmi
les chrétiens du liban députés chrétiens
fils de l'ancien président de la
république
selon human frangié tony frangié a été
tué à eden dans la régions chrétiennes
où il est député par des phalangistes
chrétiens du village voisin
les deux villages avaient souvent
l'occasion d'échanger des tirs d'obus de
mortier mais l'assassinât de tony
frangié dépasse la simple querelle de
clocher le clan frangié lundi
piliers du front libanais formé par la
majorité des partis chrétiens s'était
rapproché récemment de la syrie et
s'était même réconcilier avec les
musulmans de la ville de tripoli
la famille frangy était accusé d'avoir
trahi la cause et devait payer
l'assassinât de tony frangié consacrant
fait l'éclatement de la droite
chrétienne au liban
voilà qui intervient le jour-même du
retrait définitif des troupes
israéliennes au sud liban et il se
pourrait bien que ce nouvel incident
enrayer le processus de paix qui tant
bien que mal en tourelle la frontière
israélo-libanaise
et puis l'arrivée des casques pleine
cérémonie sans tambour ni trompette ce
matin à bint jbeil pour marquer la
troisième et dernière étape du retrait
israélien du sud liban comme pévu
l'armée israélienne au lieu de remettre
ses positions ou forces de l'onu les a
confiés aux milices de la droite
chrétienne qu'elle a considérablement
renforcé en armement israël va continuer
de jouer à fond la carte de la bonne
frontières et poursuivre sa
collaboration militaire et économique
avec les chrétiens du liban sud
avant de quitter la région israël a
organisé toute la défense des enclaves
chrétiennes relier les villages par des
fortifications
il existe à présent un véritable
bouclier chrétiens à la frontière sud
destinée à empêcher le retour des
palestiniens avant de plier bagage les
soldats israéliens ont construit pendant
plus d'un mois des héliports des routes
ils ont tracé des chemins pour leurs
blindés et bâti des postes d'observation
tout le long de la frontière en quelques
heures ils peuvent à nouveau occupé le
sud liban en cas de relance des
opérations palestinienne car israël sait
bien que son armée laisse au liban sud
une situation encore plus explosive que
lors de son intervention il y a trois
mois attentats en argentine aujourd'hui
une bombe a explosé ce matin devant le
domicile d'un responsable de
l'état-major de l'armée des dégâts mais
pas de victime
et voilà qui relance une nouvelle fois
le dossier du terrorisme et de la
situation intérieure argentine le
congrès mondial de cancérologie qui doit
en principe se tenir à buenos aires à
l'automne n'aura peut-être pas lieu si
les médecins suivent la position de
certains de leurs confrères français qui
refusent d'aller là bas
à commencer par l'un des plus illustres
le professeur charles lindbergh
je vous signale que le congrès en
argentine a été décidée en 1974 alors
que toute la liste peu vieilli ci
commence par des arrestations 1976 je
vous signale que ça a été la même raison
invoquée aux jeux olympiques de berlin
en 1936 alors que le choix de
l'allemagne avait été faite en 32es que
le gouvernement nazi n'a pris le pouvoir
en 1933 que par conséquent votre
acceptation est une acceptation qui dans
le droit français est absolument nulle
et non avenue parce que y'a les
conditions dans lesquelles vous avez
accepté elles ont été changés et la lys
la liste des dix mille disparus recensés
par amnesty international n'en a pas
pour autant la volonté des partisans
minoritaire du voyage à buenos aires il
se refuse à briser la communauté
scientifique pour eux on ne mélange pas
médecine hippolyte partir du moment où
on discute un problème scientifique
je crois qu'il faut essayer d'oublier
toutes ces croyances dans les autres
demain
nous allons en argentine il pouvoir des
scientifiques et à moins que ceux-ci
puissent avoir un intérêt sur le plan du
respect des droits de l'homme ne venait
pas et la délégation française n'a pas
la moindre intention d'entrer en contact
avec les milieux politiques argentins
pour ceux qui hésitent encore il reste
la possibilité de participer au contre
congrès de cancérologie organisée par
les médecins favorable au boycott se
tiendra aussi en octobre mais à paris
j'ai là un livre qui peut peut-être
conforter la position du professeur
façonne berg et il est signé vous le
voyez de la commission les droits de
l'homme en argentine il s'appelle
dossier d'un génocide
j'ai flammarion avec nous maintenant
l'un des footballeurs français qui
revient précisément d'argent t-il ils
sont neuf à ne pas être resté là bas au
brésil pour des vacances neuf parmi
lesquels didier six lors didier si je
tiens tout d'abord à vous dire la
rédaction d'antenne 2 et d'une façon
générale le public français a estimé
vous étiez l'un des meilleurs joueurs
là-bas malgré le but raté que nous
verrons tout à l'heure et qui avait été
effectivement l'un des tournants de la
qualification de la france
cela dit la france est quand même battu
et on va chercher des excuses bien sûr
alors on va beaucoup parler de
l'environnement on a dit d'abord que
vous aviez des peronnes d'hébergement
d'argent de politique d'entente avec vos
dirigeants leur veissid thorgal et les
dossiers un pari assez rapidement
l'hébergement d'abord c'était si grave
que ça nous nous a dit surtout que nous
étions dans une prison je n'ai pas vite
barreaux où nous étions secundo le seul
problème qu'il ya c'est peut-être les
chambres les chambres qui était étroite
pour
pour des chambres doubles mais ça va ça
va vous empêcher tout est longue mais ça
ne nous a pas que j'ai joué avant tout
il y avait les terrains de football qui
c'était a dit m alors l'argent
maintenant ça la plus grasse et à faire
est ce que ça vraiment antoine homé vos
rapports les uns avec les autres
il n'y a pas eu vraiment d'argent dans
le dans le contexte coupe du monde entre
joueurs c'est-à-dire il ya eu un
problème avec des chaussures et une
publicité où nous n'avions pas voulu
faire les bandes
vous avez fait la mauvaise tête à ce
moment là nous n'avons pas fait un
mauvais set nous n'avons nous avons
parlé bien avant de ce problème c'était
le moment de répéter ce à quelques
heures du match
je répète nous n'avons pas voulu comme
beaucoup de journaux de la presse a dit
bas du haut niveau chaussures avec deux
couleurs différentes
nous n'avons pas fait les bandes
qu'habituellement nous faisons c'était
17 c'était différent et le seul problème
à cette nuit là ce n'est pas une
question d'argent j'avais passé c'est
seulement une question de principe
nous sommes joueurs professionnels et
c'était pour maintenir notre profession
din din est ce que précisément vous avez
eu un comportement d'adulte la presse
que l'équipe de france a été vraiment
responsable on a trop dit que vous aviez
considérer la qualification comme une
fin et que en argentine vous sentiez pas
suffisamment motivé les joueurs qui ne
sont pas motivés du mot j'en connais pas
beaucoup et secundo si nous avions
dépassé le son retour nous aurions passé
sous le manteau volontiers alors didier
six on va regarder ensemble ce fameux
but que vous avez raté contre
l'argentine et qui a peut-être
effectivement décidé du sort définitif
des français qu'est ce qui s'est passé
dans votre tête
quand vous êtes arrivé comme on va le
voir devant le gardien filiol alors on
voit d'abord platini vous passez une
très belle balle vous arriver et vous
raté de très peu un mini m ou 2 qu'est
ce qui s'est passé dans votre tête
sur le premier la première action quand
je suis parti j'ai vraiment avoir un
joueur derrière moi alors que vous alors
que j'étais tout série après avoir vu de
l'action à la télé argentine
vous en voulez on vous sent bien on s'en
veut toujours quand on rate une action
qui a été six y est vous qui auraient pu
faire valoir au groupe une aventure
meilleur mais je pense difficilement
pouvoir jouer autrement sur cette action
peut-être rentrées d'argent mais si je
me fais prendre le ballon en dribblant
le gardien on est vrai pourquoi pourquoi
ne pas partir et de suite dernière
question didier six est ce que vous avez
été perturbé par cette campagne qui a
été fait en faveur des vingt-deux
français disparus est-ce que vous avez
été personnellement atteint touché et
ému
est ce que vous êtes senti perturbée
dans votre préparation psychologique
ben le comité de la fédération c'est à
dire le président et d'autres dirigeants
en ont discuté avec les joueurs et ça en
résulter que nous avons laissé en tire
carte blanche aux dirigeantes au
président pour essayer de faire quelque
chose suite à cet essai nous avons nous
avons retenu des résultats que nous
allons communiquer la presse pour le
temps et vous en êtes fier content
d'avoir contribué ce n'est pas que je
pense que
nous avons aussi quelque chose c'est
déjà beaucoup
parce qu'en argentine le gouvernement et
ce qui est sûr le prendre comme il est
il nous a bien reçu je crois que c'est
surtout le fait d'avoir voulu essayer
quelque chose qui est avant tout à
mettre en test
elle est une toute dernière question
sportive celle fois ci qui va gagner ou
d'humains city finaliste c'est difficile
l'italie pour moi est un favori mais
c'est difficile à dire merci dd si ce
sport toujours on avait déjà traversé la
manche à la nage on l'avait fait aussi
en baignoire et bien la mode semble être
désormais à la planche à voile je vous
le disais hier un français vient de
battre le record de la traversée
alors voici la preuve en images
by la chaîne pourquoi une traversée de
la manche en planche à voile
parce je pense qu'une traversée de
l'atlantique ce serait beaucoup trop
grand pour moi et je pense que dans un
premier temps c'est plus sympathique de
voir la côte qui va bientôt me recevoir
j'ai quand même temps pratiquez-vous la
planche en panne j'ai commencé un
quelques années très épisodiquement
fonce sur ce sport depuis un an et demi
environ
frédéric beauchesne a 24 ans et la
traversée de la manche n'est pour lui
qu'un pari fou une première aventure qui
ne prend pas très au sérieux
quarante kilomètres de pleine mer sur
une planche instable muni d'un mât
capricieux c'est malgré tout une
performance athlétique appréciable
peut-être pas un exploit impossible mais
un petit exploit quand même le départ
s'est fait hier matin d'où il était 8
heures 45
le soleil était au rendez vous et le
vent léger conditions idéales pour la
pratique de la planche et pour la
performance sportive
l'arrivée a eu lieu quatre heures et
demie plus tard 25 km au sud de calais
alors que la mère commençaient à se
durcir et que le vent forcissait donc
tout s'est bien passé pour frédéric
beauchesne qui n'était pas trop marqué
par son effort
quelques heures après interrogé sur ses
projets il évoquait la possibilité de
rallier cherbourg à l'île de wight pour
7 à tête
rien d'impossible son prochain projet
est celui d'un doux dingues
il voudrait avec un ami traverser
l'atlantique via les canaries à bord
d'un catamaran de la taille d'un
dériveur
mais ça aussi c'est une autre histoire
deuxième invité de ce journal vous voyez
c'est une femme de nick 100 da vedette
d'un film qui sort aujourd'hui à paris
et donnera sa bande de grandes villes et
qu'ils appellent les survivants de la
fin du monde un film typiquement
hollywoodien et qui est passée loin de
ceux qui sont votre d'habitude c'est à
dire ceux qui vous ont lancé les
bressans les bertolucci ce fossé c'est
curieux non et bien c'est l'amérique
sait mais bikini et il est vrai c'est
très différent
je suis allé là bas pour la première
fois j'avais une petite peur un trouble
de launois avant de partir et puis
j'avais envie d'y aller parce que je ne
sais pas du tout ce ce continent et
j'étais comme beaucoup de monde qui va
là-bas fasciné parce que c'est
complètement une autre d'autres choses
différentes de l'europe très différentes
fasciné pendant comme ça deux semaines
raspes fait quelque chose grandissait en
moi je comprenais pas très bien il est
petit à petit je me suis aperçu je pense
que c'est hollywood qui comme ça que les
gens là bas n'ont pas d'âme
et ça ça m'a fait et j'ai réalisé ce
avec le recul du temps ça fait pas là
bas ce qui domine évidemment si c'est
hollywood si le monde du cinéma je pense
que dans les jeunes qui vivent en dehors
de hollywood et doit y avoir un
mouvement contre ça mais ce que j'ai vu
moi ce sont des gens du rpt vicié et
c'est un monde très difficile de mix en
date est ce que vous trouvez que depuis
une femme douce vous avez bien tourner
dans tous les sens du terme est ce que
vous allez bien évolué il écoute et je
vous dis une femme douce pour moi ça
reste dans mon coeur
le film plus beaux que j'ai fait et je
les revues il en revenant d'amérique
lier que j'avais besoin qu'on choisit
d'amérique de prendre une bouffée d'air
frais et je me suis fait projeter une
femme douce dans une petite salle à
paris et j'étais heureuse que mon
beau-père imaginer de bresson à
hollywood
vous allez revenir à bresson ou à ce
genre de film dit un téléthon vous savez
je ne reviens pas je vais je vais j'ai
fait ce film qui est un beau film qui
est un film qui est visible par tout le
monde
contrairement aux films que je fais
d'habitude qui que les enfants peuvent
aller voir que je pense jamais n'a même
mon fils voix et la prochaine fois ce
sera une autre expérience et chaque fois
ce sera une autre expérience donc
retourné nous aller de l'avant et les
choisir des choses qui me passionnent
j'essaierai de faire contaminer la météo
aujourd'hui temps couvert et
températures en baisse vous l'avez
constaté pour demain dans la matinée le
temps sera nuageux sur la plus grande
partie du pays mais dans l'après midi
devait être éclaircis apparaître en
particulier vous voyez dans le sud
quelques averses ont cependant à
craindre dans l'est et le sud ouest avec
de tendance orageuse températures en
hausse
quand même notre dernier journal très
présente et à 23h30 à peu près par
pyrale un bonsoir à tous a2a demain
20h30 pour le dernier jour